pope francis is on the second day of his
momentous four-day visit to iraq
iraqi security forces are deploying
about ten thousand personnel to protect
him
as he embarks on his first international
trip since the outbreak of the pandemic
chris livesay is traveling with the pope
and reports on what has been
an historic morning
for the first time pope francis and
iraq's senior shia muslim cleric
grand ayatollah ali al-sistani joining
behind closed doors
over two faiths in a landmark encounter
at the ayatollah's home in the holy city
of najaf
francis thanked him in the shiite
community for raising its voice
in defense of the persecuted affirming
the sacredness of human life
a vatican statement said after the
ayatollah francis traveled to meet with
iraqi members of each abrahamic faith
islam christianity and judaism
the ancient city of ur is said to be the
birthplace of abraham of the old
testament
today it's the scene of a historic
meeting with pope francis
and members of three world religions
that all call him their patriarch
hostility extremism and violence are not
born of a religious heart
he said their betrayals of religion
overcoming such betrayals is a key theme
of francis's visit to iraq
the first of any pontiff as he witnesses
the country's minority christian
community
among the oldest on earth dwindle amid
decades of sectarian unrest
we are under threat of extinction says a
christian woman
if we stay like this with christian
families being displaced
if the christians aren't protected then
immigration is the next step
yesterday on his first day in the
country francis prayed inside a baghdad
church where jihadists
massacred dozens of people in 2010
and tomorrow he'll head north to iraq's
christian heartland
where refugees once displaced by the
islamic state are now
returning and preparing for the pope
francis will even visit the former isis
stronghold
of mosul where once jihadists carried
out wholesale slaughter and desecration
pope francis will soon pray for cbs this
morning saturday
chris lipsey ur iraq